[Music]
in the beginning
there was a big bang except there wasn't
here is a theory that tells us
everything from the first fraction of a
second to present day
but that picture does not tell us what
was there before
that's the fundamental mystery of
cosmology why was it like that
these are all ideas which are hugely
speculative based on a lot more
interpretations and metaphysical
assumptions
than is commonly supposed that's the
weak point of conventional cosmology
and then we take those theories and just
import them to the big bang where we see
that they just fit all the observations
perfectly there as well
i'm going to start at the beginning and
as you all know
in the beginning there was a big bang
except there wasn't
this is not what the beginning of the
universe looked like
there was no bang in the big bang theory
there's no explosion
in the big bang theory in fact um
and this may come as a bit of a surprise
the big bang theory
has absolutely nothing to say about the
question
of how the universe started what it does
describe
is what the universe looked like when it
was very much younger
and the entire theory is based on an
extremely simple premise
it's the following we look out in the
universe around us
and we see all the stars and the
galaxies and all of those galaxies
are moving further away so tomorrow
they're going to be further away from
each other than they
are today the big bang theory really
just winds the clock back
and makes the very obvious observation
that if you go
back into the past everything's closer
together
so the big bang theory takes that and
just pushes it to the most extreme
limit imaginable it suggests the
following
as you squeeze things closer together
they get hotter and the big bang theory
says that
if you take that to the limit there was
a time in the very distant past
it's about 14 billion years ago when
there were no stars there were no
galaxies there were no planets
instead the entire universe was filled
with a fireball
this is the entire universe this is the
the history of history itself
that this uh sort of you know white
blurry bit here is what we would
colloquially call the big
bang for the first period of the
universe there was a fireball which
filled the universe
this is this kind of mottled green and
blue uh
color in the diagram here but at some
point of course that the fireball
cooled at around 380 000 years
after the big bang and then when it
cooled there was a bunch of stuff
more or less just hydrogen atoms but
very slowly
over a long period of time the hydrogen
started
to gather and clump together it did this
just because of gravity and as they got
bigger the pressure inside the clump
would get larger and larger after about
500 million years
the pressure inside the clumps got so
large that the hydrogen ignited
this was the birth of the very first
stars there are stars being born there
are stars dying when they die they have
these wonderful supernova explosions
they spew out all these heavy elements
that they've created into the void
forms new stars it forms galaxies it
forms planets and the reason we know
it's true
is because we can see it so this is the
photograph
of the fireball that filled the big bang
in the early universe
it's called the cosmic microwave
background radiation there are bits in
the fiber
that are hot they're red and there are
bits in the fibers that are cold
they're blue and there's information
in these flickers 380 000 years after
the big bang
at this time the fireball is roughly
100 thousand degrees centigrade
at a hundred thousand degrees centigrade
atoms
melt the electrons just can't cling on
anymore so they get stripped away
from the nucleus of the atom so at this
temperature what you have is a gas not
of atoms but a gas of the nuclei
and then electrons which are which are
flying around it's usually called a
plasma rather than a gas
so that that's what's going on so that's
380 000 years and now we wind the clock
back
and as we go backwards in time things
get hotter until you reach a temperature
we get this right of 10 000 million
celsius okay that's 10 to the 10 degrees
um it takes a long time for things to
get that hot long time going backwards
um you reach this temperature only when
you get to 100th of a second
after the big bang itself but one
hundredth of a second after the big bang
you hit this temperature at this
temperature nuclei melt
that means that the nuclei contain
protons and neutrons but when you hit
this temperature they fall apart into
just
protons and neutrons they can't stick
together anymore
okay that's one hundredth of a second
after the big bang
then we go further back in time
until we reach one millionth of a second
after the big bang one millionth of a
second after the big bang
the temperature is 10 to the 13 degrees
and now the protons and neutrons melt
when you get to a million for a
millionth of a second after the big bang
the higgs boson melts
so these temperatures the higgs boson
stops giving mass to everything else and
all the other particles that are
floating around suddenly become really
kind of light and breezy and they they
fly around this is the stuff that we're
sure
happened that we just we just know about
and i'd like to explain why
um it's because all the things that i've
listed here
to one degree or another we can recreate
here on earth we can develop theories
which will work perfectly for these
situations
and then we take those theories and just
import them to the big bang where we see
that they just fit all the observations
perfectly there as well
we know exactly what the universe was
doing one minute after
the very beginning of the big bang that
first minute is a little bit
up for grant might the big bang theory
be mistaken
sean would you like to to start right so
to answer that we first have to say
what we mean by the big bang theory
because this phrase is
meant in two very different contexts
right
we all know the universe is expanding so
if you run the clock backwards if you
run the film uh to the past 14 billion
years ago
it was in a hot dense state and we have
something called the big bang
model of cosmology which is simply the
statement that
14 billion years ago the universe was in
a hot dense state it expanded and cooled
and went from being very smooth
to relatively lumpy which it is right
now with all these stars and galaxies
and so forth
that's the big bang model it is true
there's no point in doubting the big
bang model okay we don't let people up
here on stage if they doubt that part of
the big bang model
but if you take seriously general
relativity and you say well what
happened at the very beginning what
happens if so we
know exactly what the universe was doing
one minute after
the very beginning of the big bang okay
from one minute
after to 14 billion years after we
understand that first minute
is a little bit up for grabs so uh
classical general relativity the theory
that einstein gave us for space and time
would say according to roger and stephen
hawking
that at that moment t equals zero at the
very beginning there was a singularity
but there's also this thing called
quantum mechanics which gets in the way
which is not part of general relativity
so if you want to say the big bang
event the big bang moment the beginning
of everything
we don't know whether that is right or
not we have room as theoretical
physicists and cosmologists to invent
new scenarios
and debate over which is right which is
wrong and so that's where our
disagreement comes in um i'm pretty
agnostic to be honest about whether or
not that moment
because it's a moment in time the big
bang not a place in space it's not
an explosion in a pre-existing space
it's the beginning of everything it's
the moment before which
there were no other moments and that's
the model and the question is is that
model right
so i i have two favorite theories and
neither one of them is roger's favorite
theory so that gives us something to
talk about
um the one theory that i think is is
very
at least on the table is plausible is
yes
that is the beginning of the universe
and it's because time
and space themselves are not fundamental
that when you get deep into the guts of
quantum mechanics
you realize that all the stuff around us
the tables the chairs
space itself time itself are emergent
approximate phenomena they're like
talking about the air
as a fluid with a temperature and a
pressure rather than talking about the
molecules maybe even
time is just a good approximation
and it started 14 billion years ago
that's one possibility that i think is
very plausible
the other if time is truly fundamental
if time is
real and there and inextricable from the
fundamental equations
then i think it's very likely that the
big bang was not the beginning
in that case but i also think that as
roger has
emphasized better than anyone there's
something very profound about the nature
of time
in our observable universe namely that
it has a direction
right that the past is different from
the future and if we can get into this i
hope
the reason why the past is different
from the future in your everyday life
the reason why you remember yesterday
and not tomorrow
is ultimately because of what conditions
were like at the big bang
that's what set up the arrow of time and
that's the fundamental mystery of
cosmology
why was it like that so my favorite view
of that is that there is a
much larger universe that we don't see
that our little universe is a tiny
little part of the whole picture
and the whole picture is actually
symmetric that there are people in our
past
who think that we are in their past the
time runs in the opposite direction for
them
as it does for us this is not by any
means
set in stone we don't know it for sure
but these are the kinds of
scenarios that we're talking about as
professional cosmologists to understand
why the universe that we do live in
looks the way it does we eventually run
into a face of the universe where
all the matter was plasma anything
before that
is just speculation we have very good
evidence that the universe is expanding
i think there's pretty much no one in
the scientific community who would doubt
that
and it follows from this that if we try
to
run the evolution of the universe back
in time
the universe must have been smaller it
must have been denser
and with that we eventually run into a
face of the universe where all the
matter was
just one hot plasma with fluctuations in
it
and i think up to this point uh we're
we're on pretty safe ground um yes we
did have to introduce some new things
like dark matter and dark energy to
actually
make this time evolution pitch fit with
the observations
uh but having said that it works just
fine now if we try to go further beyond
that
it gets much more complicated because
there's um
if we go back in time we go to higher
and higher energy scales
and at some point they get higher than
the energy scales that we have been able
to test so far
um the highest energies that we have
tested were probed at the large hadron
collider
and anything before that is just
speculation so you can continue to push
the theories to higher and higher
energies
uh but really we we don't know if that's
actually what's going on and
now there are lots of um theoretical
physicists who nevertheless have come up
with theories for that
um so all this matter is supposed to be
um created by some other field uh the
infertion field there is supposed to be
a phase of exponential expansion that's
called inflation
um which is also supposed to be caused
by that field and ultimately the
universe
supposedly came out of some quantum
fluctuation and so on
and so these are all ideas which are
hugely
speculative uh and i personally think
the evidence is not very good for that
um there is some evidence that one can
discuss
and then beyond this there is this
question like uh
where did it all come from the core i
think it rests on a lot of faith that
there actually are universal
mathematical laws that hold true far
beyond what's possible to test
my philosophical work is on the limits
of scientific knowledge and so
for me why i got interested in cosmology
is because i think this is the science
where the lines between metaphysics and
physics or
faith and knowledge are the most
obviously blurred and this calls for
some
some questioning um and
the big bang theory is really based on a
lot more interpretations and
metaphysical assumptions than is
commonly supposed
and at the core i think it rests on a
lot of faith that they actually are
universal mathematical laws that hold
true far beyond what's possible to test
and so just to put this very briefly in
perspective we know already with
reasonable confidence from observation
and testing that
general relativity works for about 0.1
of the universe according to big bang
theory so the big bang model
is essentially an extension of
einstein's general relativity
into the remaining 99.9 percent of the
theoretical universe
and although there are ways that which
we can measure using measuring methods
to get far beyond this
and to probe beyond the or 1.0.1 percent
the further out we go the more model
dependent we also become
and it becomes more and more difficult
to calculate things with precision
and this is why you see so many
different discrepancies pop up
in in the last years when it comes to
measurements
so
[Music]
all of this to say is i think that there
are lots of problems with the model that
are not generally
acknowledged and that makes it worth
asking the question
the question for the big bang itself is
from my point of view obviously beyond
what we can say
anything about imperative
any alternative to the big bang has a
very high
evidentiary bar to clear
if we frame the big bang as the fact
that the universe started in a hot dense
state
roughly 14 billion years ago i think the
evidence is
very very strong for that premise and
everything i'm about to say does not
depend on the nature of dark energy or
dark matter those
absolutely affect the expansion history
but they don't affect
what i'm going to say as evidence for
the big bang itself
and i agree i'm an observer so i think
cosmology should be empirical
driven by observations and the basic
observation is red ship
which is one of the few pure observables
in cosmology
so we have the recession velocity of
galaxies proportional to distance
known for a century and most obviously
interpreted as a 3d
uniform expansion with no center so
copernican principle holds
in the context of general relativity the
hubble law represents expanding space
time this is an exercise we give our
advanced undergraduates the dynamical
evolution of the
is part of the theory it's predicted and
once you trace the expansion backwards
you
infer that there should be relic
radiation left over from the dense hot
state
it was predicted and a rough temperature
assigned in the 1940s and less than 20
years later accidentally observed by
radio astronomers
it's almost perfectly smooth or
isotropic and
almost perfectly thermal with a
temperature just under three degrees
kelvin
a big check mark on the whole idea and
this radiation
fits the idea of the universe becoming
transparent as stable atoms form when it
was about a thousand times
hotter and a thousand times smaller than
it is now
i'll also point to a large pile of
evidence that's that's kind of messy but
it's a lot of astrophysics about cosmic
evolution the fact that the evolution
of galaxies and active galaxies and the
radiation
of the universe and the regions between
the galaxies there's many observations
that point to evolution
consistent and concordant with a early
hot dense state that's
that's a lot of astrophysics in there
and then the light
element abundances are a primary piece
of evidence for the big bang
stars in the universe over cosmic
history could not have created
a quarter of the universe by mass and
helium the big bang theory accounts for
that
and then in a completely different
observational realm the
isotope of hydrogen deuterium which is
essentially primordial
intergalactic gas one part and ten to
the five in abundance
also matches perfectly with the big bang
model with no free parameters basically
because the only free parameter
originally was the baryon to photon
ratio which has been measured
by microwave observations so i guess to
finish i would say
that any alternative to the big bang as
i framed it
has a very high evidentiary bar to clear
and it's not true that other theories
haven't been looked at tired light has
been looked at and ruled out
and so and there are cycling models
obviously that can finesse a big bang
but in the terms of the basic idea again
independent of dark matter and dark
energy in their nature i think it hangs
together very well
there's consistency checks on the age
from the age of individual stars so
independent of expansion history the age
cross checks
so i think it's a strong theory
it is not wrong and by big bang i in
cosmic inflation
it is not wrong it's incomplete
cosmic inflation gives us this beautiful
picture where
the large-scale structure in the
universe and the cosmic microwave
background
basically everything we observe around
us is seeded from those primordial
quantum fluctuations
and how the whole universe started small
and stretched all its
non-uniformities as as
cosmic inflation made that universe to
accelerate and grow big very quickly
so we have a set of observations our
precision cosmologist is a very advanced
field by now
so all our observations agree perfectly
well
with this picture of cosmic inflation it
does not mean they prove
cosmic inflation it's conceivable that
someone else might come along with
a different picture that also agrees
with this set of observations
however we are happy because here is a
theory that tells us
everything from the first fraction of a
second to present day
and we know our universe started small
and it's growing
but that picture does not tell us what
gave that first
energy and what was there before and
what lies beyond
our universe is uh about 10 to the power
27 centimeters the visible universe
and it's only 13.8 billion years old
these are big numbers but but they are
not inconceivably big
so we all of us have tried to ask what
was there
13.9 billion years ago or what was that
what's beyond 10 to the power 27
centimeters
the big bang was not the beginning there
was an eon prior to us one before that
one before that etc
there was supposed to be something
within the first
10 to the minus 32 seconds now what does
that mean you think of a number
one fraction the bottom the denominator
is a number which has 32 digits
and that fraction ridiculously small
fraction of a second
the universe was supposed to have
expanded far more rapidly
than anything that we're aware of now
it's called an exponential
expansion which is supposed to have
taken place and that's called inflation
and it is very much part of conventional
cosmology
now to me that's the weak point of
conventional cosmology because
you you have to introduce ideas which
there's no other reason for apart from
making it do this but apart from that if
you go one
blip after that i completely agree with
what sean's saying
so the argument has to be from before
that
and i'm claiming that although there was
this idea of a steady state model
which i grew up with i may say when i
was in cambridge as a graduate student
this was all going on and dennis sharma
was a good friend of mine and bondi and
gold and
people i used to know fred hoyle and
they were all dead keen on this idea
that the universe went on expanding
expanding
and it didn't change much because new
matter was created all the time
okay i like that theory because
philosophically it meant there was no
beginning and you could talk about the
universe
in that kind of way now i'm picking up
on that in a
different way though i'm not disagreeing
with the big bang there was a big bang
i am rather disagreeing that quantum
mechanics
was important there and that's a big
point of difference
really the reason that you're allowed to
continue
before the big bang which is what i'm
trying to claim is because
in a certain sense i'm agreeing with
sean that you don't have time
how do we measure time we have
extraordinarily accurate clocks
today because a particle of mass
is really a clock and this based on the
two basic
most famous formulae of 20th century
physics namely einstein's
e equals m c squared which tells you
energy and mass equivalent
and max planck's e equals h nu or f
whatever you call it it tells you the
energy and frequency equivalent
put the two together that tells you that
mass and frequency
are equivalent that tells you that if
you have a massive particle
it is a clock of extraordinary precision
now the point is when you don't have
massive particles and this would apply
to the remote future
when basically the universe is dominated
by photons running around
either from stars or from black holes
you see stephen hawking his most famous
discovery if you like or a theoretical
discovery was that black holes
are not completely black or they're not
completely cold
that they have a temperature that
temperature is so low
that it's much lower than anything you
could build in the lab certainly with
the big
biggest black holes uh sun uh
galaxy has a black hole in its center
which is about
four million times the mass of the sun
that's so cold that it
puts everything else in the shade one
minute
now the thing is that according to
hawking these things eventually
will evaporate away because the universe
gets colder than the black holes
they evaporate away and disappear so
when those have disappeared
there's nothing left but things which
don't have any mass there's the photons
basically that's true and that they're
the only way
of you don't have clocks anymore because
you don't have mass and so the remote
future you have no way of keeping time
and the idea is that this remote future
where you have this expansion of the
universe
which is becoming exponential expansion
which is what we currently observe
continues forever now i found that a
really depressing picture
it seems to me you know the universe is
pretty exciting now but then you know
what you've got
eternity of boredom but then i thought
who's going to be bored not well not us
because we won't be around
the main things that will be out there
were photons and it's very hard to bore
a photon i'll tell you
because photons the main reason is
probably they don't experience anything
but that's not the point
the main point is that they don't
measure time
photons right up to infinity and they're
still there and they say what
what we've got to do with the universe
they're still there the idea is that the
universe continues with what i call
another eon
our eons started with the big bang and
ends with this
ex exponential expansion that then
roger becomes the big bang of another
eon and there was an e on before
i could go and talk endlessly with this
if you allow me but
the question is the big bang was not the
beginning there was an eon prior to us
one before that one before that etc
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
[Music]
tv
[Music]
you